con lágrimas en los ojos cientos de
miles de ucranianos huyen de su país de
día de noche a pie en tren o en carro en
la medida que las fuerzas rusas lanzan
ataques coordinados con misiles de
crucero y artillería sobre kiev y otras
ciudades
sólo su niñez y su venta que fue severo
éramos absolutamente libres y vivíamos
como queríamos hasta que interfirieron
horriblemente en nuestras vidas matan a
los civiles y bombardean las casas de
los civiles con cohetes
y para qué
tengo que escribir
las familias aspiran a entrar en polonia
eslovaquia rumanía hungría y moldavia
mientras tanto se refugian en pabellones
deportivos y estaciones de tren donde
reciben abrigo alimentos y en algunos
casos juguetes las normas ucranianas
impiden que los hombres de entre 18 y 60
años que puedan ser llamados al combate
crucen las fronteras las agencias de
ayuda de la onu afirman que la guerra
podría llevar hasta 5 millones de
ucranianos entre los más de 44 millones
de habitantes a huir al extranjero con
hasta 3 millones dirigiéndose solo a
polonia